so people would say what's the moral of
the story right and so that's what they
want to ask when they listen to a fairy
tale and the truth is that there's
something implicit which is more
important than whatever moral you think
you should get out of this story there's
some participation some mirror of
reality something that is that is
reflecting to you something precious and
powerful and some sometimes beautiful
sometimes tragic but it's more than a
moral and that's where like it seems
like that's the feminine thing it's very
elusive it's implicit not explicit and
the mistake people try to make is they
try to when you try to make the implicit
explicit I think that's when it gets
into like propaganda ter that's when it
gets into like you're hitting people
over the head with it and they you know
if they want to hear a sermon they'll go
to church you know they don't want to
hear
[Music]
it
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world so hello everyone I am excited to
be speaking to Kendall Hoyer uh Kendall
is someone who worked at Disney for many
many years and she's now co-head of
story at Sky dance studios she is an
animator but mostly she is someone who
does storyboard art she she kind of
takes the ideas from the script and from
the director and actually creates the
basic bones of the of the story that
bring it all together and so when you
watch a movie She that she's worked on
she some of the scenes she will have
worked out in detail of what how the
characters react and where they are and
everything so it's a really a joy to be
able to talk to someone like that and
see how her thinking storytelling
thinking how she bring symbolism into
that and her experience as an artist so
Kendall thanks for coming to join me
yeah it's my pleasure so Kendall maybe
tell me a little bit about what exactly
it is that you do oh um I'm a storyboard
artist so I work with the director and
other storyboard artists to board out
the movie so I story We storyboard out
scenes and eventually those scenes get
cut together to make a entire story reel
of uh the movie and it's almost like a
comic book version of the movie It's
almost like the blueprint of the movie
before it moves to other departments
like animation and lighting and layout
and all these other departments that end
up building the movie in production so
we we watch our reals and we judge the
movie The Story basically on if it's
working what's not working and then we
oftentimes tear it apart and rebuild it
again like four months later so we're in
this constant it's almost like rewriting
we're doing iterations of the movie to
really try to hone in on the story and
make it the best could be so that that's
my job is to like
take the story The the script Pages or
description of moment in the movie and
flesh it out with like because that is
camera environment acting character like
all that stuff yeah okay so let's let's
say if I ask you this like just to to
figure it out what's the difference
between you and the director the
director he makes the final call he
makes the final call so it's very very
collaborative which is great like this
is the same model that at Disney and at
Pixar it's like a very
collaborative um and some other Studios
but Disney this is really the Disney
Pixar model and because the head of our
studio John ler came from Disney Pixar
he brought that model over here it's
great because you it's kind of like the
best idea in the room wins it's very
collaborative and creative so the
difference between me and the director
is I don't have the final call however I
sometimes will be like is that what you
really want or is that what we should do
because remember the that might
contradict this like in the hierarchy
the the main story Point like look and I
can point out to them like this isn't
really you know driving with this idea
over here and that's where like I might
say like symbolic thinking is really has
kind of honed my story senses because
I'm like I can kind of see how you know
things are more hierarchical and I can
see the the patterns um overall you know
like and it helps it helps me I feel
like I already kind of had a story
mindset because I I discover obviously
you were doing that before I was doing
that before I discovered you guys's um
podcasts and stuff like that but um it
helped a lot right and sometimes it
makes something implicit more explicit
like because you have these intuitions
it's not easy to explain them and and
and so sometimes it can give you tools
to kind of in for sure for sure I think
I can recognize things that are implicit
uh quicker perhaps and like put my
finger on them you know what I mean like
because I I I'm like oh that's that I
can call it what it is where some people
don't they're just they're not aware of
those things yeah so in your job that
means that if you're working on a
project you have
to you have to adapt whatever you're
doing to the style of the project and be
able to draw the characters and be able
to like yeah scene yeah yeah like like
if you were animating have to like be
able to kind of draw them on model to a
certain degree although sometimes we
don't have models for characters we just
have like it's gonna kind of look like
this you're just like oh okay just go
for it right if it's not a main
character I imagine they don't put as
much time designed yet yeah So
eventually these these characters are
modeled and then it goes to a different
department which is called from here it
goes to edit and then it goes to where
they take my boards and they put it
together with Sound and Music and they
make like a story reel is what we call
it and eventually we will watch the
whole movie in this form to see really
okay wow yeah multiple times we we watch
every couple months we watch them to
judge if it's the story is working and
that's how we kind of um hone in on how
the story is coming along to see if it's
coherent and then we bring in people
from the studio to um other writers and
directors and also everybody in the
studio gives notes and with those notes
we go oh this isn't working there's a
problem in this area this isn't working
it's kind of like metacognition for the
story I guess within the studio as
that's Veri thing doesn't um yeah so
that's it's kind of like that way we can
pinpoint the problem areas and sometimes
we'll take people's suggestions but most
of the time people are like um everybody
is like pointing in the same areas where
we see that something isn't working and
that's how you know there's patterns in
stories because everybody will almost
always one Rises to the surface
something is it's always similar across
the board H and so in some ways the
animation you know before you put in the
massive amounts of of investment you
need to get it animated you know what
the movie is going to be pretty much
yeah you're F figuring it out although
it's it's kind of simultaneous usually
the schedule is we get about you get a
couple iterations
of scripts scriptment sometimes
treatments and then they go to boards
and we get three screenings before
things have to enter
production and that means when we'll
after like the third screening or so
they'll look at the movie and go this
scene is is working and we don't foresee
it changing too much in the future send
that one to production and there's all
these other things that have to get done
in production like the models for the
characters have to get built the sets
have to get built they all have to get
designed first by right artist and then
they have to get built in the computer
by a 3D artist and then yeah so there's
and there's all kinds of uh computer
simulation tests and things that people
working on all at the same time it's
very labor intensive imagine yeah and so
so that mean that sometimes you are
working with let's say certain set
designers that would have worked on some
sets before you're you're going in yes
well yeah they take it so uh we kind of
work with them the director works with
all the Departments that's the
difference between me and the director
too director is seeing it through all
the way down the line yeah from like
color and design and camera work and all
these things like he's seeing everything
through um but eventually these boards
will get input and edit and then the
layout department will take kind of like
what I did here and they might not have
the exact set I draw because I I try to
stay close to what we have but sometimes
I kind of just make things up they'll
try to get the spirit of what I'm doing
and they'll they'll set the cameras in
the set because like within the computer
right there's a digital set it's already
there yeah it's already there and they
have the camera and they can place it
and they lock off shots and those locked
off shots then those go to the animators
and the animators do the performance on
the character within those shots and
then from there it kind of other things
happen like effects and
simulations and water simulations and
lighting lighting is really important
and all these other departments that
touch the shot before it gets done and
usually gets much better each time and
when you see the final thing you're like
whoa yeah yeah wow and so it's like the
fact that it's so labor intensive and
that there's no
possible
improvisational aspect to it it's it's
surprising that you could have an
animation by the time to put it out that
has like bad stories in
it like how does that because you
because you would think if you have
people looking at it and you they can
actually see the story play out like and
these are professionals wouldn't they
know if it's a bad story like wouldn't
they be able to tell I feel like they
can kind of tell but they don't know
what the problem is it's almost always a
problem of not going deep
enough with
the you know theme essentially like what
what it's talking about
and you know how you talk about layers
of reality so like
it's you know if the deepest level's
here or the deepest level's higher
whatever they're like somewhere in the
middle and they don't know how to go to
the next level of depth that would unify
the parts and let some parts fall off
sometimes they get people get caught up
in like something that they're like oh
but this is just so beautiful but the
story is about this and then like yeah
but when you have that moment in a movie
uh that doesn't speak to the broader
thing the movie feels fractured and
disjointed it's not all pointing to the
same thing like the best movies right
are firing on all cylinders in the sense
that they all have they're all pointing
to the same thing right like story
carries that the theme right but also
then the the set design the light
all those choices are pointing to one
thing and um but if you get caught up
somewhere in the
middle and you want this sequence to be
just really cool and whatever but it's
saying something different than what you
have in your final conclusion scene then
it's like they're not people are like
wait what what was that about oh that
didn't tie into this oh okay you know
that that tends to happen yeah so people
get like they like a certain bit of
writing or like a little exchange and
they're not willing to sacrifice it to
the to to the bigger the bigger hole
Yeah or sometimes they I think they
can't see the bigger hole sometimes or
they can't they think that one sentiment
might be like the deepest there is I
think this comes from a
materialistic perspective too because
it's harder to perceive like you said to
to see the idiosyncrasies that are
evident in exchanges or that are evident
in a character's Journey but you're not
you can't you can't it's like you can't
see it you can't perceive it or you you
don't see it in your own life so you
can't see it in in the character's life
I don't know it's just just sometimes I
notice that people can't see it they
can't yeah so they they so if you have
you not have you have you had a
moment like have you had moments where
you've worked on something and like you
thought it was all good and whatever and
then later you look back at it and you
thought how couldn't how did I miss this
like how did I didn't see this weird
thing about it or this like this bump or
this
this this I mean I I haven't had as much
um say in uh other projects as the one I
have now because now I'm in a position
where I have more um you have more power
now than you did before yeah I have more
access now to to say something before
when I was just a stus and I would I
would say
things um but it wasn't in the room all
the time to you know to really uh TR to
get to the bottom of it and sometimes it
takes a while to
get to the bottom of what something
really is about like because the what
how the process works is the director
usually has a couple different ideas and
they they don't know
necessarily what what's at the base of
those ideas it's just like there's
something intriguing about this you know
and then uh the creative director or
executive creative executive producer
like comes in and says okay develop this
idea out of the three like they pick one
out of the three and they say go in this
direction and so they start to develop
that and as they're developing it they
start to see kind of a story and they
start to develop the world the
environment that the story is going to
take place in the other characters and
excuse me the basic story
structure um but they I I wouldn't say
that they have the theme in hand and it
kind of it's like I think it's like when
people say they write a book and like it
it starts speaking to them it'll start
speaking It's just sometimes I don't
think everybody listens
fully but there's something about you
know like we talk about these animated
movies there's something about the early
Pixar
movies that were that seemed like they
were really able to
just it's hard to explain it like they
just had a Mastery of Storytelling and
also of
characterization also because they were
doing animation they didn't have to the
the characterizations didn't have to be
you know complex like he would in some
you I don't know some Oscar winning you
know movie but the characterizations
were were captured so well you know like
it was hard it was magical right it's
like the the first Toy Story or monsters
incorporated or there these these these
early Pixar movies where there was
something about it when when the story
finished we were really mesmerized by
just how much they will to capture even
in terms of you know the the way the the
movie The Story twisted and turned and
how kind of came back in the end and how
all these threads ended up being brought
back uh the writing was just astounding
um and so yeah so that's why that's why
like in some ways they they kind of
ruined us for animation because it's as
if it was the first blowout of of real
3D animated movies and they did such a
great job that now like everything's
measured at the light of these early
Pixar
movies I
mean they were like the other good thing
that they had uh for them at that time
is
like less pressure almost like and less
you know like voices in the room but
maybe they're not in the room you know
just less uh top down bureaucracy for
lack of a better words you know just
like they were a small group and ideas
could free flow and you know they were
like let's do it you know they like you
know more Taking Chances and it's that
kind of creative environment that you
kind of have to
like it may come easy when you're small
in a smaller studio and you you've got
something to prove but as soon as you've
proved something that kind of pressure
comes you know starts Turning Heads
people oh I want a part of that or you
know and it starts to protect the
creative uh
environment you actually has you have to
protect it to a certain degree actually
right right I mean that's interesting to
to think about you know and
it's interesting that in some ways you
could imagine that some a studio like
Pixar ended up being the the victim of
their own success like you said which is
that they attracted so much attention
you know bought by gigant the biggest
cor biggest entertainment Corporation
and then then
basically the stakes are so high now
every time every time you now every
these movies are so expensive too
because the stakes keeps getting higher
that I imagine the pressure in the room
is different from a bunch of I don't
know like guys finished college that are
just going you just kind of just
bouncing things off the wall until it
totally sticks and and bring it together
yeah I think there's probably different
pressures when you're at that level than
when you're at the top and I think and
you're at the top there's more voices
and
more I don't know like money pressure
and like you know expectation and things
like that which can really kind of drag
you drag you down I think creatively
hard
yeah never been in that position I've
never been a director I don't I can't
imagine like the pressure that they they
hear you know uh that that they that
they have to deal they have to deal with
so hope you hope that they'll protect
their creative crew so that they don't
have to feel that heat so
much and that's where
somebody is to have a creative person in
charge that UND really understands the
creative process to kind of protect the
creatives underneath them is really
important like um you know
because the business side is the
business side you know they're they
businessing which they have to be you
know that's important yeah can't do what
we do without that side of it but also
there's a certain aspect that you have
to create uh create like a buffer or
protection between the people just
trying to be creative you know yeah
yeah I mean that's really interesting
like what I what I find interesting
about what you're saying because you
wonder like when I see the bad movies
come out and I and I'm like what how is
it possible because you think they're
definitely creative people like it's not
like there's a dir of people with great
ideas and a dir of people that tell good
stories but in some ways maybe it's just
that pressure that's so high coming from
people who aren't creative who want to
make sure that I mean it's it's it's not
anybody's fault in particular but it's
like if your movie has to generate a
billion dollars I mean the pressure for
of something like that is so crazy that
that it has to it has to kind of like
come down onto the the people that
ultimately are the resource to make it
happen right and it becomes kind of like
a beast in and of itself because the
more you I guess succumb to like making
things more expensive the more that
cycle just kind of perpetuates itself in
a way because you just well that one was
really big we got to make a big you know
one on this one you know just kind of
like spins kind of out of control in a
way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think
we're reach it seems like we're at the
end of that like it seems like whatever
the next wave of things is going to be
is not it's just not going to be it's
like what do you do after endgame like
what do you do after these like massive
huge you know really well done and
successful like things that then it's
like well I there's just nowhere to go
after that if all you're trying to do is
make it more fireworks like you you
can't come back back to come back to
Story come back to character come back
to to Simple Things real things yeah I
mean I think people are really looking
for like real and
authentic things you know yeah small
things I think I don't know did you see
have you have you followed a little bit
our snow white thing have you seen a
little bit of what we're doing yeah yeah
it's great I I bought it I'm waiting for
my oh cool I'm happy I'm gonna read it
to my daughter she's she's about to turn
seven so she perfect perfect yeah
where're it's like I'm listening very
carefully to what you're saying because
in some
ways you know it's like I I think I
think that it is possible right now to
make very powerful beautiful things but
but in some ways you have to have the
right really the right people but then
also the right Spirit of of of of
creative possibilities in order for it
to
happen yeah yeah yeah yeah to like
protect that thing and
um I think you know the other thing that
I think people like or maybe wanting or
they need is something that gives them
something to reach for something that's
so much of things like are like
story-wise they're not like aspirational
you know they're just kind of like
here's what it is you know yeah it's
kind of a downer it's like oh yeah that
is how it is you know as opposed to
something that's like look at this
beautiful
thing you know and you know people might
criticize that's just idealistic that's
never whatever but it gives people
something to aim for that's higher that
um that they can look up to you know
stories that that give them something
and also stories like that but where
they can find themselves in it where
they like the psychology of the
character is real you know and that's
another thing that's really that's hard
to do I think it's um finding a
character that's interesting
relatable appealing right that you're
like uh you're like oh I'm on board with
them like I I know what they're feeling
in this moment I really understand what
their what wound is we talk about that
sometimes like what's a character's like
flaw and wound what what drives a
character you
know have you do
right uh no well I no I haven't ever
written I you say no you say that do you
have story
ideas yeah some story ideas
yeah and why wouldn't you want
to right yeah I don't know I I just I'm
always a picture
person but I mean I don't hate I like
words but you know I just I haven't no
but WR not in the sense of I don't care
about the writing part what I mean is in
the sense of creating stories oh like
creating your own
stories yes I probably should should
probably
should I like I just do my work and then
I do my mom duties like take my da B and
all these things and then by the end of
the day I'm like oh but I I should try
to make time for that sort of thing how
long have you been doing
this uh I started I in 2008 as a story
artist wow so that's and now you're head
of story I'm a co-head of story co-head
of story yeah so I have another uh
cooworker who's doing the job with me
which is super helpful and what does
that mean head what does it mean the
head of story well um uh our job is to
oversee the storyboard artist team and
also to um be in the meetings with the
writers and the director to uh kind of
almost like Shepherd the story and kind
of help the director find the story and
and then carry that Vision through in
the boards in the story boards and now
the project you're working on now this
is the first time you're doing this like
as yeah this is the first time I've been
head a story yeah and how how is that
well it's great it's great because
that's why in this job I have more um
say because the director is really great
he has Us in like all these meetings and
because we're in all these meetings I
can really see the story like if you're
not in all the meetings like little
things get changed all the time but if
you're in all the meetings you're like
oh okay I know why that's there I know
that's there no way that's there and
this needs to accomplish this and this
charact we need to have a moment around
this area where a character realizes
this because you have to track their
character Arc right you have to figure
out you know because all the little
pieces have to come together you got to
do the main character the secondary
character the world problem like all
these things need to track throughout
you need to lay
enough pipe in the story so that it
feels cohesive at the end right you're
trying to like have all these things
come together
at the end in the conclusion and feel
satisfactory um so you can really track
that if you're in all the meetings yeah
and all the discussions about the story
and so it's super fun because I really
really enjoy talking about story and
character and really figuring
out I like story problems because it
creates an opportunity to to solve
something pick something yeah yeah yeah
what did you study to do
this uh I studied animation okay and I
like you I went to art school but I
animation
illustration um so yeah yeah yeah and I
always wanted to work in animation since
I was like eight you know when I was
like eight I was like I want work at
Disney like many kids and praise the
Lord I did you actually went you
actually went for it and ended up doing
it yeah yeah um but yeah I studied
drawing you know in high school I was
that kid with a Sketchbook yeah
at youth group
drawing yeah yeah yeah always drawing so
yeah I mean this is weird but there's a
difference between how I think the
public
perceives entertainment or movies and
stuff like that in terms of actors and
all that stuff like that stuff is really
secondary like it's it's like they get
the money but that who cares really like
the the the important thing are the the
important people are the
storytellers yeah yeah the storytellers
are the writers and ultimately the
directors that take the story and make
it into something
you yeah and they take you on a journey
with with the actors and the the
cinematographer and the lighting and the
set dresser and all that stuff and
that's why it all has the director has
to be the keeper of whatever here is at
the top like the thing that everything
needs to be pointing to and if they
don't know what that is then everybody
else is in trouble right yeah and so and
so s so we need we need for people that
are thinking about storytelling and are
realizing that that's really the key to
to to to talk to each other so yeah
anyway so like in my case that's what I
want to do like I I have to stop
complaining about stories and I have to
try to to to tell better story so that's
what that's kind of the the the vision
I've given myself in the next few years
with this fairy tale series but then
also God's dog and then other stories
that I have in mind yeah and so
hopefully we can also attract people
around that like people who who
are so anyways that's my I mean like
ultim you know I feel like I've never
heard of so many people interested in
like I mean as as people more and more
people recognize wow Hollywood's really
not doing good things other people are
like well we'll do good things you know
just like everybody's you know and um
which is good because it creates
opportunities for other things to arise
as the other as the established system
seems to be
floundering um but you know I think some
you have to like go into it soberly and
like also be really like led into it
because I think that uh it's it's harder
than it well at least for animation
so Stud I'm like really you really know
what that takes like you need backers
and you need someone at the head of that
that understands it and like I mean I
don't even understand it like all the
like um things that need to come
together for that to work it's like it's
it's a lot the massive Enterprise
definitely no I you know that's true
especially if you want to make really
quality things because obviously you can
pump out animation now easy more easily
than anytime in the history like you
could animate without knowing anything
about animation and then you look at
you're like yeah and then it's horrible
and then and then and then nobody nobody
cares so so maybe tell me a bit about
how how kind of symbolic ideas has
influence your your work like how you
you feel like you're able to integrate
some of the things you've been that that
I talk about or that or that you know
Jordan talks about and into
storytelling yeah well I'll tell you how
I came across Jordan I came across
Jordan first and had like well because
I'm always looking at stuff and you know
film making things and story things
anyway and I think I was looking up I
had heard that Akira kurasawa uh was
influenced by doeski stories and so I
was looking up doeski and I found
Jordan's video about
Doki his personality uh series I was
like wow this is really interesting and
so I started following and around that
same time he became kind of
controversial
and people this was like back in 2016
like 2015 2016 when was it it was later
than it might have been it was either
early 2018 or late 2017 I think yeah
yeah yeah well that's when it really
blew like it really blew up yeah it was
starting to blow up and people were
talking about how this guy is
really what he's misogynistic he's this
that the other really I don't disagree
with anything that he's saying I'm like
oh okay and so I just kind of kept my
interest to myself and just watched all
his videos by myself and then I think he
had you on and I was like wow that's
really interesting and then I looked up
your channel and you had like all these
things about movies I was like oh cool
and so I watched a bunch of that so it
that shook my worldview yeah like I had
pretty much been living in
um you know for like you know very
worldly like I was raised in the church
but then during college I kind of fell
away and then
uh so when I discovered all these things
like Jordan and you my worldview had
already been shifting like I'd come back
to God and like I was questioning
everything and it really kind of um
things that I had been experiencing by
having God in my life again were really
resonating with what Jordan was saying
when like he talked about the bottom
falling out I was like I know what that
feels like um and everything all the
things that he would describe I'm like
yes that's what happens yes that's what
happen happened that's what it feels
like um phenomen
phenomenologically and um
so all those things really spoke to my
personal experience but also I could
apply them to what I would see in the
story room or what I was seeing in
stories like I was like oh that's that
principle that you guys talk about or
you know when you kind of peel away the
materialistic View and you see that
really the spirit is the ontological
truth you can see things more clearly
you know and I feel that's what
symbolism is very connected to the
spiritual realm so it's very like uh
it's it's like that represents that that
thing in the story is this principle in
kind of the spiritual realm it's
symbolic of something that's unseen and
and the more I could see those things
the more I could kind of um problem
solve stories so I think that like
listening to you and
Jordan um I didn't discover John Riki
till a couple years later I think um we
kind of really just opening my eyes to
seeing
things not materialistically and seeing
things and patter stories and patterns
as
more lack of a better word more
spiritual in a sense and it just made it
clearer to me to see the pieces moving
underneath the the physical reality mhm
yeah it's hard to talk about these
things I understand yeah and so
definitely one of the issues that people
complain about in terms of the modern
movies is in some ways a lot of some of
the decisions that seem to be made are
not based on the needs of the story
itself but it come from outside the
story like some message or some thing
they want to get through and it and that
and that it's it seems artificial or
tacked on because the the story it's
itself doesn't need it or the the it
actually sometimes goes against the
basic pattern of the story yeah yeah and
I I think um that was kind of like where
I seeing like I think sometimes people
can't they they see like sometimes those
things those those values as the highest
value like the best the like that's the
deepest point of the movie or that's the
theme or that's what it should be about
and they try to it's like I always
compare it to trying to hammer in a a
square peg in a round hole or something
it's like you're trying to make it fit
but it just doesn't fit but you'll bend
over backwards because you think that
that's the most important thing and it
comes from not listening to the story or
the characters of what this movie is
really trying to say just like if you
know you were writing a novel and you
weren't really listening to what the
characters would say or who that
character is like you would make them
act in a way that's was counter to what
you had established before you know yeah
and people go like well that character
wouldn't do that and he pulls you out of
this suspension of disbelief and it
because it's just like the doesn't jive
with reality it doesn't jive with the
patterns in reality it doesn't jive with
what you've previously set up nobody
would act that way in that situation
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then yeah but
it's interesting
because right it's like that's when you
can see that in some ways the highest
form of reality is not because we used
we we tend to think something like even
myself you know writing fairy tales so
people would say what's the moral of the
story right and so that's what they want
to ask when they when they listen to a
fairy tale and the truth is that there's
something implicit which is more
important than whatever moral you think
you should get out of this story there's
some there's some participation some
mirror of reality something that is that
is reflecting to something precious and
Powerful
and sometimes beautiful sometimes tragic
sometimes you know but it but it's more
than a moral right and it's
um yeah like uh like and that's where
like it seems like that's the feminine
thing you know like it's it's very
elusive it's implicit not explicit and
the mistake people try to make is they
try to when you try to make the implicit
explicit I think that's when it gets
into like propaganda terit that's when
it gets into like you're hitting people
over the head with it and they you know
if they to hear a sermon they'll go to
church you know they don't want to hear
it um and I have a little posted I have
tons of Post-its on my screen but one of
them is avoid
didacticism and it's because I I learned
that word I was like oh that's what we
want to avoid
diac um because and there's a time and
place for it like I mean I feel like
asops
fables or um there's some you know
there's some things that are like for
children that have more of a a little
more of that that dactic it has that
aspect to it but as you get older you
don't want it to be so explicit you know
you're more you're in a story you're
more like kind of asking questions in a
certain area like a certain like over
around a certain value and you can't
strawman the opposing value or it feels
didactic you have to let the the anti
hero or whatever the antithesis be as
strong as the the um the protagonist or
whatever because otherwise it feels
rigged it feels rigged I love that word
I never thought of you thinking about it
that way it feels rigged yeah that's a
that's a great idea and then and then it
makes you realize in some ways that like
you said that there's something about a
story which is rather a puzzle of human
experience that is playing out and that
there is in there is a solution but the
solution is within the puzzle of the
story it's not it's not a it's not just
a a a a Mor a moral tale that comes in
from from outside and obviously we're
not the first ones doing this right the
whole deos Sakina idea was that was like
you know Aristotle complained about the
playwrights not making the characters
work out the story from within their own
motivations rather than rather bring in
you know at the end someone who just
solves the problem from outside and just
basically tells you what you know what
the moral is so that you can go back
home you know with a nice package right
and and as a Storyteller I feel like you
have to be aware of the
audience the characters you're creating
and yourself you have to be aware of
like what you yourself are putting in
there you know because or what you
already like have in your
head uh in like in the story like so
many times I feel like I've been on
projects where it's like I feel like um
we are like yeah we're saying this and
we know that this is what it is in the
story but we should take that out of it
because by this shot or saying this
we're imposing ourselves as the
storytellers onto the characters right
and the if you do that too much the
audience feels it and it doesn't feel
right yeah yeah and it's a and you can
imagine like you can also you can
imagine it too that as so the person
telling the story you're like well this
is what I want people to get from this
story and so the danger of course is is
that that's what you want so you make it
too explicit and then by the time you
make it to explicit you've you haven't
succeeded because nobody cares about
your story anyways and so it's like you
you've lost if you try to make your
point or whatever it is you think you're
you're you're making and so the and so
what happens I think too is like if you
if you remain in story mode and in the
kind of Story puzzle mode where you have
these factions and characters that play
off each other that balance each other
out you know that that that relate to
each other in ways that is that is in
the puzzle of the story I think what it
does too is that it can make someone say
something deeper than what they capable
of yeah I do think that that that I you
can just see it starting to emerge like
like somehow you just stumble across it
and you're like oh my gosh that's so
much deeper than than we could have even
like constructed it just starts to kind
of happen it it it's like things start
lining up you know the things are
starting to line up and it just kind of
flows it's strange but it it happens if
you don't fight it though somehow like
that's the you have to almost get get
yourself out of the way as the as the
Storyteller it's almost like a conduit
you have to kind of Shepherd it but you
can't get in the way yeah yeah yeah no
it seems like that I think you're you're
totally right that's why
sometimes like the best
storytellers and this is true like in
terms of Music in terms of all kinds of
sometimes those you don't really want to
hear the people tell you what it's about
because actually they don't really know
what it's about or they think they know
but once you once you see you're like
well what you're saying is actually
reducing the the the movie or the song
or whatever like the reason why people
actually care about it um that's a
that's a and so in some ways that the
Storyteller is almost like a it's like
an antenna almost more than it's someone
who's just basically vibing in the
puzzle and is able to to put it out
there but it doesn't even necessarily
understand it's not even to their own to
their own Merit sometimes that that
they're able to that they've been able
to do something like that yeah I think
so and then the Muse idea becomes way
more coherent like we can kind of
understand why the Ancients you not just
the pagans the Christians too you know
in the Middle Ages they and even in the
Renaissance people were still uh
invoking the Muse before they started
because in some ways knew that doesn't
totally come from you yeah there's like
a
you kind of have yeah you're like some
sort of conduit you're have you just
kind of have to Shepherd it and I think
the more you do it the more you kind of
you know recognize where you're
inserting yourself and where you're just
letting things flow uh to a certain
extent and you know you've been in
Creative or I don't know I've been in
Creative rooms you know that did I
there's a certain flow that happens in
Creative rooms too where things just go
back and forth and they just kind of go
and there's ones where it's just like oh
can't say that well well that's that you
know you just start putting blockades up
in your own mind you know like they're
not going to like that or this that and
the other so that's true I mean I mean
when you when you are creating something
and there's that flow like really the
way that John REI talks about it there
really is this Theos right that John
also brings up which is that in the end
the there's more than what you thought
was possible there's definitely more
than what you could have done on your
own
and that's really precious I mean if you
can have that it's quite rare and it's
really precious and that's probably you
know like you talked about the like the
early Pixar movies or even the early
Disney movies or you know other projects
like that where there was probably some
of that going on like there was just
this really bubbling thing where the
ideas just jived and everything was just
kind of falling together in a way that
was that was intuitively right you know
right I mean I think like to use like I
mean I don't know but like early Disney
as example I think Walt Disney and his
brother were kind of like the business
people like protecting their little Hive
of uh creatives and they had they they
amass all these great creatives but then
they they interfaced with like I'm I'm
sure they were hustling to try to get
money and funding to keep this thing
going right but they were also
protecting their little Hive of artists
you know trying to give them like the
best that they could and they also were
Visionary like we're going to need this
and this is going to be great and so
they're yeah they're like shepherding
the creative process and moving it
forward you know but for sure there
there's something unreasonable about
those early Disney movies I mean when I
I remember just a few years ago I
watched pinocchia again and I was
looking watching that animated waves and
I was thinking this is completely
unreasonable like how the hell did they
how did that how did they who did this
like who animated the water like just
and it's all you know it's all hand done
and everything and there's just
something so completely unreasonable
about about it and uh but also this you
can just feel the absolute care and love
like like if you're looking at a
handcrafted violin or something right
yeah and the they you know and like
early Pixar they created they had they
were Visionary and they wanted to tell
the story and they they wanted to do it
with such care that they cre technology
they bring in like people that can help
them to do these things and that's kind
of where like you know early Pixar would
talk about like
art and pushes on technology and
Technology helps the art and it kind of
they kind of move forward together
because sometimes the artist can't quite
you know they can't they don't have the
tools to create what they want and so
the the the technological people will
come in and help them create like the
multiplay camera like that wasn't the
thing right you know and they created
that to do Snow White so that they could
get these the feeling of these you know
of one layer moving this way and that
way so you felt like a camera moving and
you know all this stuff and it gave
depth and um Beauty to the the shots of
the the final product you know like but
they didn't have that before they had to
create that yeah so I'm gonna I think I
think maybe I'll end with the dark
question sorry to end with the dark
question but the so AI is all the buzz
and everybody is talking about Ai and
and you can see you know the different
software the different uh platforms that
are like stable diffusion and a mid
journey and all these platforms that are
kind of pushing on us uh and so what do
you
think in terms of as we watch this kind
of these techn these massive
technological innovations down the
coming Downstream how do you see the
future of this like of animation of
creative storytelling uh in relationship
to the the these Tech tools that are
just coming down very fast um well
honestly I don't know that much about AI
like you probably understand more than I
do I really don't understand that much
about it but I think I think it's I tend
to think it's kind of a hack you know
like
people it's also robbing people of
something right like um there's a
certain amount of like gratification and
um that happens when you put in the time
to to do something and you and you you
overcome and you overcome and then you
you have something you're like wow that
looks great you know but now people are
like using AI to get there faster and
I'm you know I'm not about like not
getting something faster you know like
to a certain degree but you're like
robbing people of um excellence in a
certain sense you know by giving it to
the machine and giving it to some
program somewhere that like you know if
you spend hours drawing and really
honing your craft that can't be taken
away from you right that can't be taken
away from you that's something that
you've put in the attention and the time
to do um and I think AI kind of robs
people of that you know like that
handcrafted thing is so valuable I think
it
devalues some things if if it was just a
machine algorithm yeah and what do you
think of the idea that in some ways like
the best way to frame it is something
like care and attention in the sense
that even
though the tech the the computer might
bring to us like technically proficient
images that will be very fast to produce
and will be visually stunning and and
and surprising and all that uh but that
because it's so
easy the type of care and attention you
would need
in order to create something that people
will
love will like you won't it's like as if
you won't have to put that in there
because it it can happen so fast and
that will
necessarily affect
the the the result and it'll and it'll
necessarily affect the the perception
that people have of that result as well
but I I think people can tell for sure
like you said I think people can
perceive that something does doesn't
have that level of um care and attention
you know that um and that I feel like
it's just going to you know some people
will be like oh that's great but then
when something comes out that really has
the care and
attention people are going to like walk
on to it because they can I think we're
just built to notice things like that
you know I don't know well I mean we're
artists it's hard for me to know how how
objective I am but for sure like now
I've seen in the past six months I would
say maybe a little more I've seen a huge
percent of ads on line get replaced by
mid Journey images um and I not only can
I tell but there's something about it
like there's something that it I don't
know how to explain it there's something
about those images that are boring even
though they're all stunning and they
have all the right light angles and they
have this this kind of uh Perfection
there's something about a lot of these
images that are
boring um and and repulsive to some
extent uh and so I mean I'm curious if
it's just because I'm an artist and I
can tell and I'm like it's like oh
please another mid Journey image like if
I just scroll down my Facebook whatever
thing or all I see are just a bunch of
mid Journey generated ads and people use
it for thumbnails too on on on YouTube A
lot of people are using mid Journey for
thumbnails on YouTube
and there's something about it that is
just not uh that I find very
uninteresting but it's almost like
something really flashy at the flashy
really F like it's just obviously it's
flashy you know but then it it wears off
really fast yeah I I mean I'm also an
artist so I probably have a similar like
mindset to you like I'm also like uh my
eye is really attracted to things that
are like handcrafted or there's
something and know something just
something nicer about you know like
handcrafted things and I I tend to have
like I'm like oh look at that one and
then I'm like oh look it's really
expensive and there's a reason for that
handcraft like dog on it um but um yeah
and and a long time ago I I turned off
to most of the like um comic book movies
because like oh same thing again it's
like flashy flashy flashy it's like the
same thing and my mind just kind of
shuts it down um I don't know if
everybody will be like that you know but
but I do think that if you create
something uh that is really good quality
and appeals to people it's not like high
artsy or whatever that it will attract
their attention I I I think people are
just built to see things like that like
their early Pixar movies or the early
Disney movies like things like that like
people are drawn to them you know and
they they withstand time yeah definitely
definitely so well thanks for your time
Kendall appreciate it oh that's
great next year February 29th to March
2nd we're are going to have the very
first symbolic World Summit in Tarpon
Springs Florida a lot of people involved
in the symbolic World Community will
come together to explore how we can
recover the ancient Cosmic
image to further this community and to
further this type of thinking in the
world